emilie magazine sur le site internet
d'un grand magasin elie des niches la
robe de ses rêves
elle fait son achat en ligne emilie suis
sur le web
l'acheminement de son colis une semaine
plus tard elle n'a toujours pas reçu sa
robe elle contacte la compagnie d'yves
raison on lui apprend que son colis a
été laissée chez un voisin lequel aucune
idée et des voisins
emilien en a beaucoup elle habite une
course de 50 logements elle cogne à la
porte de ses voisins immédiats
aucun semble-t-il n'a reçu sont cognés
emilie rappelle la compagnie d'yves
raison on ne peut rien pour elle la
compagnie lui dit on s'est conformé aux
modes de livraison choisi par le
commerçant effet le commerçant prévoyait
que le livreur pouvait les cils colis
chez un voisin
si la cliente était absente emilia tel
un recours oui mais son recours doit
s'exercer contre le commerçant puisque
si lui qui s'était engagé à livrer sarov
la loi lui permet d'annuler son achat si
après 30 jours
elle n'a toujours pas reçu son colis le
fin mot de l'histoire
même si vous achetez dans un magasin
virtuel les obligations du commerçant
elles sont pieds rires